好 大家早上好 上週是美國獨立日啊
所以那個整體市場來說的話是比較清淡的
就是美股的話你會看到這週一
就是昨天下跌了一點 下跌0.75
那麼這個中間呢主要有
其實我覺得也不光是這個Big Beautiful Bill
闖關成功
主要是Trump那些Trump就是那些Terror Policy
他又公布了不少的國家嘛
他給很多國家寫了信了
就是你的關稅多少 你的關稅多少
關稅多少
然後 但我覺得這個不是一個特別大的負面
就是整體來說一下Big Beautiful Bill
就是這個大的法案
因為我之前預測這個法案還要拖一拖
沒想到共和黨還是很強啊
就是硬把這個法案給通關了
在參議院的話就最後Vance那一票
然後眾議院好像是擦4票 擦幾票
然後就通關了
通關以後我覺得就首先分析下這個法案吧
這個法案中間包括伊隆這些人對他購併比較多的是
他的Budget Deficit Increase增加了多少的這個債務
那這個事情本身和共和黨內部的就是共和黨
不是一個非常想大政府的政黨
所以呢他們對於Budget Deficit Increase
覺得是比較反對
而且像伊隆這些都比較反對
那這個呢我個人感覺不是一個大問題
這個事情我們之前反反覆覆說過
就是特別是對於美國那個進入一個債務週期
其實是可能是進入一個資產泡沫週期
然後呢對於經濟體本身沒有很大的影響
因為美國的這個特殊地位吧
就是美元在全球經濟體或者金融上面的這種特殊地位
導致他這個債務絕對不是一個問題
那麼其他呢就是我覺得
其他他這個中間比較重要的是幾個方面
第一個方面是解法
Deregulation不光是對於石油
對於那個因為以前美國對於這個環保
環保極上主義做的是比較極致的
就比方說你要去開個油礦
或者你要去開個那個比方說稀土礦
稀土礦在美國很多
但是你開不出來
對吧因為裡面污染很嚴重
所以你要去開稀土礦
那這些東西會受到影響
所以他這方面的Deregulation
就對於各方面的包括環保
包括很多的審批
他進行了去檢管
那麼去檢管是一個宗旨
在這個法案上是個宗旨
那最終的話他又完成去檢管
其實還是路滿滿齊修演戲
這個沒有幾個季度肯定是搞不定的
因為中間有很多的部門
包括這個部門根深蒂固的
關於環保的這些測評啊這些東西
它還是需要一步一步的去把它去掉的
那個Deregulation
第二部分的Texcut就是減稅
那減稅其實就等於是發錢
所以我上週的話
其實講到過這個BBB法案
對於整個經濟的影響
綜合BBB法案和關稅的話
對於明年經濟可能負面影響
0.25左右
就是綜合起來
對於經濟基本面
沒有特別大的負面影響
但是至少他延續了繼續花錢嘛
對於這個法案本身肯定是利好
那Deregulation中間比較重要的
Deregulation在哪裡
在於銀行層面
上週我們可能講過SLR
SLR這也是我們認為可能後面
就SLR其實我具體來說
它分成幾個部分
就第一個就是什麼樣的資產
可以被認為成我的capital資產
不需要被納入我的槓桿的考慮
那麼原來的話就是很多的褲旁保安
它都是根據它的風險程度
根據它WAR的程度
要進入它的風險資產
那現在來說的話
它的Deregulation之後
它去買Bali
去買這些中短期的債
中短期的美債
那麼其實就跟處理就跟現金差不多
所以它的槓桿比率要求就會下降
第二它本身對於銀行的資產
資產槓桿比率的要求就會下降
就本來好像是6.5了
現在Deregulation之後會好很多
所以就是我上週簡單計算的話
大概4萬億
高盛認為大概有5萬億
5萬億美元左右的ban capital
會被released出來
銀行的這個資本會被釋放出來
並不是說這個5萬億
直接鋪到市場上面去了
而是說這個5萬億
是銀行本來不可動用的資本
不可以拿來買國債
不可以拿來做各種各樣的事情的錢
那現在可以拿來做
比如說買國債
或買一些就是投資
那麼中間會有一部分的錢
會被return回到那個share hold那裡去
就比方說它要
原來它6.5以上
就是6.5
這個你的你的槓桿率是比方說
是6.5以下的話
你不可以分紅
你不可以發獎金
那麼銀行的獎金分紅
可能會又慢慢回到08年主動水平
所以我覺得很多事情
是一個一個大的周期
像08年以後
銀行行業投資銀行行業
肯定不是一個大周期裡面
那麼deregulation之後
會不會是個大周期呢
我覺得不好說有可能是
所以所以是這個
那麼BBB法案
另外一個就是我們講到deficit
和那個債務的問題
中間其實就要說到
它在通過法案之後
會不會馬上去發債
會發多少債
但這個是大家很多的人
在問到我要關心的一個問題
那麼這個事情分成兩部分
就是說我們先在週五的時候
好像這週五
你要先去看一下
它8月份可能會有一個財政部的問卷
就是這個裡面的就是給了
財政部會給一個guidance
給一個預期
就是第一方面我發bill和發coupon
分別大概是什麼樣的比率
因為現在大概是23碼
然後我預期不怎麼會改變
因為美國如果說大規模
像川普之前發推特說的
發大量的bill
那這個等於印很多的錢
這是會導致很嚴重的通脹的
那反過來會影響美聯儲的
各種各樣的動作
我影響美聯儲
其實影響美聯儲降息
反而沒有錢去買bally
去買那個中期的國債
或長期的國債
這個原因我待會說一下
所以我感覺是bill和coupon的比率
不會太大變化
但是這個是一方面它要說的
那第二方面就是它要說
這個長債回購的比率和計劃
然後發債的計劃
其實最終就是決定了
這個東西會最終決定
我債務的供應是多少
怎麼樣供應
供應在那些tanner
那些期限上面
那市場其實已經開始定價了
這個就是個是什麼
這個是那個OIS
ONI interest resource
和GC的這個區別
GC是那個collateralize
就像一個是
一個是無制壓的銀行階段
一個是有制壓的銀行階段
那這個區別就是越高的話
也代表銀行就是整個市場
對資金的需求更大
那制壓品不足嘛
那麼一般來說
我們認為是它和TGA
就是tratric generate account
我們之前說過
你可以簡單理解成
就是國財政部存在美聯儲的錢
那這個錢越多的話
就相當於存在美聯儲
那就不在市場上
就等於市場上錢就會越少
那麼TGA越增加大概1000億左右
這個rate是要上去4到5個visus point的
現在pricing了Halfway吧
我覺得
因為現在市場關注的焦點
包括對星期五的溫泉調查的焦點
就是TGA是不是會很快的
回到8500億的這個需求
現在大概4800億
然後要回到8500億
那麼TGA的上升
代表著在222上面就是
reverse report上面在抽水
就市場上抽水
也就代表了結果
就是gcovois spread
gcovois spread和上升
現在上升了一半
in anticipation
就是市場預期
會把TGA重新build up
因為beautiful bill已經過了
然後他們要繼續發展
所以在非常短期裡面
短債的話
可能在市場上會抽掉一點水
然後的話
常債也會有一個發行的週期
但是具體發行多少
這個數字我們要再看
但這並不意味著
意味著就是市場上
很多中國人擔心
美國國債逃發了很多
然後10年期果
人力越大百分之5
那這件事情是不存在的
因為後面我們還會有
那個ESLR的解保
ESLR的解保
意味著銀行可以買入更多的國債
但是銀行買入更多的國債
它這個買入並不是在現在
一旦解保
它解保也不是今天馬上解保
它馬上可以實施的
而是說它要有利可圖
它才會去買
銀行買國債最多的是亞券
就是短期債比較低
然後長期債比較稍微高
那麼一點點
那麼我就是買一個短期債
去養一個長期債
然後做這個事情
如果不上資產負債表
那像我們以前的那個
RAIDAS可以無限的做
做很多很多很多
那這個一個銀行的RAIDAS
做的可能
可能比不小的
Soberwell才要大
那麼什麼情況下
它會有更大的動力去養這個債呢
就是美聯儲降息
或者說美聯儲開始溫和的降息
那擔心國債問題
就是一個擔心國債問題
第二個在自己臉上貼金
說我其實還是省了很多錢
你們這個BBB
沒有有那麼大的Budget Deficit
沒有那麼大的赤字
這個赤字是美聯儲J-PAL
你造成的
因為買利息弄得很高
所以這個才是川普的Gender
去逼就是川普的這個動機
他去逼那個J-PAL去降息的動機
那J-PAL會不會降息
我個人感覺還會
至少現在不會
就是說7月份肯定不會降
然後到9月份
他可能會觀察一下
但是有可能會在12月份降息
但是如果說J-PAL
不管anyway
他12月份總是會降
明年也是會降
明年至少降兩
如果12月份降的話
明年可能會降三次
或者甚至四次
如果9月份降的話
9月份12月份
那明年可能會降兩次
就是它會處於一個
我覺得在今年
現在開始從10月份開始
到明年年底
應該會降超過一個點
1到1.5點
大概我覺得是這個水平
那麼在這個過程中間
其實就給了去壓榨
我們叫Role Interstate
就是養圈的這幫人
一定的空間
而且ESLR的解保
也給養圈的人一定空間
他們就可以去借錢
然後collectualize
制壓我這個國債
然後不上表
然後再去買這個
買這個白利的國債
所以美債的這個需求
你們其實根本就還需要擔心
那麼關於J-PAL
就是聯儲會不會降息呢
可以看一下經濟數據吧
我覺得聯儲基本上現在就是
就說怎麼說呢
任它風吹潮動
我毀然不動
我就看經濟數據
我那個不求有功
這個是他都快卸任了
所以J-PAL現在態度
必然是這個樣子
不求有錯
但求不求有功
但求無錯
然後同時的話
觀察你的特朗普的
關稅政策會怎麼樣
所以你看
J-PAL也講到
我沒有降息
就是因為你的關稅政策
所以特朗普在關稅上面
會不會採取非常大的動作
我覺得也不太會
所以很多的tell risk
我覺得今年年初強的tell risk
現在來說
其實還是比較緩和的
那麼上週雖然說是星期五
是美國國慶假日
所以整個市場來說
相對來說比較清淡一點
但是還是有個比較重要的數據
就是失業率的數據
就每次公布能防payroll
和unemployment的數據
大家都會關注很多
那麼這次數據看上去
我總結是這樣
看上去很好
但是沒有就是
是這樣看上去似乎很好
但是背後按流擁動
就是背後看上去
其實並沒有那麼好
首先表面上unemployment數據
在4.1
大家一看那天晚上
我跟我朋友吃飯
吃飯的時候
他說你看數據看上去很好
美國的數據
感覺根本就下不來
能防payroll根本就下不來
確實能防payroll數據147
對吧 147K 14萬
我們之前說過低於12萬
才會說經濟在一個
當我出現的不太好的
低於8萬
那美聯儲就可以開始
覺得失業的情況
要比通脹要更加嚴重了
但是能防payroll在147
超過預期
然後同時的話
它的失業率在4.1
看上去是不錯
但是問題
這個中間有很強的
季節性因素
而且這個裡面
就是你拆開看
能防payroll誰在顧人
中間一半的僱傭
其實都是政府僱傭
就是政府僱傭
在這個中間佔了一半
那麼在private sector上面
私營部門上面
其實是非常
我們怎麼說呢
就非常平緩
沒有怎麼增加的
所以同時的話
你會看到私營部門的一些
僱傭的數據
包括之前ISM的service
包括ISM manufacturer
包括之前的job opening
包括ADP的那些數據
其實表現的就是
私營部門再放緩
僱傭再放緩
這個中間有可能是有
我們之前關稅的影響
也有可能有一部分的影響
其實在於我們對於
美國對於immigration
就對於移民變得更加緊
移民變更緊
這個直接影響
就業直接影響消費
這個東西都是直接的影響
所以按流勇動的意思是
我們雖然這次數據還可以
但是後面
就是我們會看到三級多
四級多的數據
一定會顯示出
你前面政策的影響
所以經濟數據方面的話
我覺得是會有影響的
包括美聯儲
也在看這個數據的影響
美聯儲其實知道
這兩期數據不會太長
它的挺難也不會動
但是它也會感覺到
後面通脹的會有影響
然後經濟數據會下勤
聚集怎麼做
是要等數據出來再說
所以回到頭來講
big beautiful bill和美債
美債長遠
不需要有任何擔心
它有無數的買盤
然後包括銀行結榜之後
它也無數的買盤
但是在短期
三到六月裡面
聯儲不動的情況下
包括ESLR
它的結榜也要到明年一劇毒
所以經濟上
然後增長上
資金層面上
其實都有一個
我們叫做清黃不見
都有一個時間差
也就是六月裡面
美債是要發不少的
但是可能美聯儲
還沒有降息到這個程度
銀行結榜之後
銀行套利的交也沒有回來
就是戰權市場
那麼在資本市場上是怎麼樣的
就是在股票市場上
我覺得是同樣的
現在S&P的估值定價了
2026年2%的增長
所以大家其實已經不太在乎
二季度經濟增長
就是這個業界增長
大概預期在4%
今年的業界增長在7%
就這個東西
大家已經不太在乎了
就是在乎的是說
我26年經濟
在這個偉大的
big beautiful bill下面
會不會繼續很好的增長
你有可能會
對 確實
我覺得這個
肯定就會增長是一個正面的東西
但是當你有清黃不接
當你中間會有一個空當期
然後這個空當期中間
搞不好經濟要軟著落的時候
我覺得市場還是會有波動
就是即使美股
我是認為美股的估值是分岔性
那我反反覆覆
也是一直維持這樣一個觀點
什麼叫分岔性
就是我們可能在未來
三季度 四季度
看到美國很多公司會調高它的預期
特別調高它的預期
這些公司
包括半導體的公司
包括特別是半導體的公司
然後包括很多AI相關的
歐國運營的公司
高科技公司
他們可能都會調高它的預期
但是傳統的公司
他們的預期可能會下調
這個就是
我覺得冰火兩種天
兩邊會不一樣
最終你會看到
可能業績增長就是7%
今年7%
像國門對於高盛的話
對於2026年的業績增長也在7%
但是市場明顯覺得
26年的業績增長是要超過7%的
因為我現在市場定價
可能GDP也增加2%
那麼最後會在7%還是9%
不好說
但是我覺得是會分岔的
有一些行業就是會很大的增長
有一些行業未必會
然後就是大部分行業未必會
所以你說指數的話
我對指數
我覺得指數是高估的
但是同時的話
高科技企業是有機會的
大概是這麼看法
但是星期一的下跌
其實主要Trump給了
那個Korea和韓國25
他直接寫了通信
說你們的關稅就是要在25
因為之前達成的這個官貿的協議
跟VNM跟越南的是20%
20%之後
越南20%之後
大家會覺得像其他的國家
可能會好一點
像和韓國和日本25
其實是在預期的上限
所以市場稍微做了一下下跌
但是你說
而且他Tariff是從7月9號
就好像是明天
他被他調到了那個8月1號去了
那麼但是他又提到
最後在Labor Day是必須要完成
就是整個貿易談判
所以大家會覺得
Anyway到9月份
這些東西全部要結束
所以到9月份的時候
那個Fat也要給出一個明確信號
到底是降還是不降
大概什麼時候降
然後Tariff到底鬧
鬧疼神什麼樣子
也要給一個結果
所以我覺得
在Reciprocal Tariff上面的文章
不會特別多
更大的文章
應該是在Section R32
就是在於特定行業的這個Tariff
那特定行業Tariff包括拜導體
包括可能銅
包括Lumber
包括那個樹
就想說這些東西的進口
那這些的Tariff會加碼
我覺得百分之一
大概率還是會加上去的
那市場現在對這個東西定價
可能沒有那麼全面吧
那很多調查報告
可能要到夏天
3月的時候才會出來
反正今年都會加上去的
那這個是
這個是我的一個感覺
但是如果說
半導體加
就比方說半導體
我剛剛講我比較看好
還是覺得半導體估值比較低
那麼
半導體就算它真的增加了這個關稅
對於飆貨台積電有多大影響
我覺得影響很小
也不是特別大影響
這個最後承擔
可能還是美國的消費者
和美國用的這些雲場上來承擔
那是為什麼
這是我前兩天跟朋友吃飯的時候
也一起聊起過一個事情
就是在AI的時代
現在時代
人變了懶之後
它很難就變了情壞了
當你習慣了去問GPT
或者你問Germany
或問Whatever
你那些AI的軟件
一些事情以後
你認認真真去做research
查Google就不太會
就是這個頻率就會減少
即使你上Google
你也可能用Google的AI在查東西
對吧
Google收入口
不影響Google廣告收入
今年廣告Google被壓得很厲害
但是問題
人家廣告收入就是很強
不影響的
Google也可以做AI
而且它是本身這個軟件公司
它AI也可以做很好的
對吧
我只是說
對於AI的使用會上升
就好像當年大家使用Google以後
就不去圖書館了
也是一個道理
那麼問題是
當你每一次使用AI的時候
它的token utilization
它token的使用是線性增加的
就不是線性
這樣是指數級增加的
所以未來只要是AI的再發展
不管是我們現在每日的活動
或者是我們去看病
醫生以後
可能也不查書了
也用AI了
對吧
或者是我們FSD用了汽車的開車
所以對於整體算力token的使用
這個東西是指數級上升的
或者是平方數
三次方數的這樣的上升
這個東西的上升的速度是100%
是一定會超過現在算力的增加
就是我們算力的增加
過去十幾年20年
因為手機受限於它的電池
所以我們需要N7 N5 N3 N2
然後台積電的支撐芯片
需要密度越來越精
然後能耗越來越好
然後用這個東西去填補手機
所以你追不上
它不是一個以量取勝的事件
但是未來token的需求是以量
需要大量的量
需要你的面積大
甚至就是片要大
然後去做更多的token的計算
然後台積電的排產是現行的
你一個EUB的廠下去就是幾百億
那個就是幾十個變鏈
30個變鏈吧
就是30個變鏈下去
然後你這個排產是能夠看得到
你25 26 27 28
能夠排產多少
所以在你現行的供應下面
你的需求是直數級的上升
現在已經看到是至少平方數
或三次方數的這樣的上升
那這個中間的gap是永遠沒辦法
沒有辦法被滿足的
所以說芯片是個賣房市場
你就算關稅
你再怎麼加都沒有用
不會來不太會影響他們
那麼隱身出來的是什麼
隱身出來的是說
可能像英特爾這種公司都會有機會
那英特爾現在說他18A
可能主要用於內部使用
18A的良率是很好
那這個我們確定還是知道
但是那個LipoTime可能會更加注重
放在14A上
就是14A是對外
18A這個node它可能對於
等下說做GPUR或者是對於做那個算法芯片
可能沒有就是
你再去做外部開發的成本
可能有點高
它意思就是我拿最新的14A
去做外部的開發
18A拿來做內部的就是PC的業務
然後提高自己的毛利率
可能可能是個意思
但是我們看到的機會是說
原來補胎願意去試
英特爾也願意去試
甚至三星大膽的
大家都有些人都願意去試
因為這是一個半導體缺貨的大周期
這個大周期的時間會拉得非常長
我在推特場很多人也說過這個問題
有些人覺得英特爾可能永遠做不出來
三星沒有希望
三星兩律一套糊塗
確實三星兩律一套糊塗
英特爾兩律不差的
但是三星兩律一套糊塗
但是大缺貨周期下面
就是能夠做的量
應該都要被吃掉了
台積電的擴產是遠遠不做的
這個是我對於半導體的一個大的方向的看法
所以你說半導體就是說那個美股的估值
確實美股估值
我覺得整體過高
但是片面性的很多的市場的故事
還是很有價值的
那最後說到那個Beautiful Bill
從前講到Stable Coin
我上次講過Stable Coin
那引申出Stable Coin
和最近大家吵了很大的AWA
是不是Stable Coin和AWA就代表的市場
就是一個牛市
我不太同意
AWA能夠做什麼
AWA能夠做的只是不做KYC
就是你能夠做去快鏈這個技術
能夠完成什麼
你AWA什麼東西都能上市
那你只要打開什麼東西
沒有SEC那麼所有東西都能上
那隨便都可以上
隨便都可以上以後
是不是會給市場帶來流動性呢
幣圈已經證明什麼東西都能上
不帶來流動性
流動性會變得越來越差
就和最近一段時間幣圈一樣
你也可以看到20年的幣圈和
現在幣圈根本就不一樣
這是我自己的一個Load
就是我自己存下來的數據過
然後出來的數據
你可以看到最近雖然幣的幣一直在漲
但是幣圈各類Token
各類幣的付房頂很嚴重
這個是每一天的付房頂
也就是說這是第一頁
我這邊可以Load出來
很多很多很多頁
給你們看看
這是第一頁
這是第二頁
第二頁有一個證的
第三頁
第四頁
第五頁
就是你可以看到幾乎是沒有正的
房頂
這和20年不一樣
大一頁大家都要做多
然後做多的人要付房頂
現在付出錢
現在是做空的人要付出錢
甚至的話
做空的人一天要付將近1%
意味著就是所有市場
現在是同一面的在做空檔
就是對於Allcoin
同一面的做空檔
而且除此之外
Allcoin還有一個特點
就是所有Allcoin的關聯度
變得非常非常低
就是你可以看到這些小幣
包括就是以太坊比特幣
這是個比特幣的關聯度
這個你看中間這一條都是關聯度
關聯度都是很高
都基本上七八十以上
當關聯度很高
就意味著小幣
其實沒有走出自己任何的行情
然後它關聯度很高
然後大家全面都在做空
這個就是整個這個幣圈的
這個現在的狀況
背後的原因就是韭菜死亡了
就是能夠去做的韭菜死亡了
所以你可以看出
現在像白貶推出
比方說你在白貶上
可以做那個期貨原油的交易
然後有人在推出去做
有人在推出去做那個
美股上煉去做交易
那這些東西有沒有最終的意義呢
你最終是需要這些持優的人
持Crypto資產人
然後願意去炒
Crypto資產人
連這種波動率200%的賭場
他都已經沒有錢去賭了
都在做空了
他們哪有可能去做那個股票
在上面買股票
而且你要買用Crypto去買
比方說因為哪個股票
連分紅都沒有
它不是一個asset
它不是一個security
對吧
secure都過SEC了
它只是一個RWA的一個資產
那你為什麼不在美股上面買呢
你在IB上面買了你有分紅
你在上面買了沒有分紅
你的價值就是零
所以我對於RWA的認知是
沒有添加新的東西
除了去監管
但是去監管之後
是劣幣驅逐良幣
還是良幣驅逐劣幣
很不好說
監管有監管篩選出了頭部
它會更有流量
更有流量東西
比方說美股上面那些資產
阿茅果隨便都可以賞
幣圈隨便都可以賞
它最終有沒有流動性的
就是這麼多頭肯有流動性
沒有
我告訴你
它流動性一直在下降
最近幾個月
當然它有一些頭肯
會爆發出很強的流動性
但是它一直是跟著標的
比特幣在走
就關聯度
基本上都是關聯度
高股市一上
然後大家就統一在做空
所以會不會有因為RWA和Stablecoin
給到幣圈山寨一個山寨季
這個我絕對不同意
我覺得肯定沒有
比特幣是另外的邏輯
那我待會講比特幣我之前講過
有另外的邏輯
Stablecoin本身
既然放到Big Beautiful Bill裡面
Stablecoin本身是有價值的
而且是有不小價值的
因為它大大擴張了美元的可視用心
原來美國金融監管很嚴
你錢打金打出都很麻煩
然後你還要進美國銀行
各種各樣銀行
然後還有Swift的結算
然後又很麻煩
但是現在比方說你做外貿
用Stablecoin
用USDT很容易
現在大家都不需要去中國外管
去結會了
也不需要錢去入到美金的帳裡面
所以確實
它是大大的延伸了美元的影響力
但是皮質不存毛將淹服
它輔在什麼上
輔在美元上面
它又沒有增加美元流動性
美元的整個貨通量也沒有
解不解決美國的債務
或者是國債問題
不解決
因為美國國債這些東西
它不需要你這個解決
它把ESLR放開一下就有了
所以Stablecoin本身
對於美國是很有價值的
但是RWA和Stablecoin絕對
對B圈的影響
對Crypto市場影響
然後我覺得是沒有那麼大的真名影響
還產生
然後說它會產生
那個沾沾大牛市不存在
我覺得未來10年大牛市在哪裡
在半導體
半導體的大牛市
是跨越這次手機週期
手機週期是半導體密度
要求它越來越精的就是
但是對於整體半導體的需求
對於算力token的這個需求
緊噴式的需求
現在我沒有看到東西可以滿足
你的算法能夠提高
每一次提高之後
它的需求還是指數計的上升
很快又會填補上
所以我覺得這個才是真正的大週期
好吧
這個是我認為大週期
我本來想講兩句中國的
那個中國的事情
要不我就放到下週再講吧
我把它放到下面去
下週再講吧
好吧
謝謝大家
我看看大家有什麼問題
然後我們可以Q&A一會